I'll see business owners obsess about
like a $200 a month bill but hire three
employees on for 80,000 year each
without even blinking an eye it's
interesting it's $250,000 a year bill
that they're committed to no matter what
no matter what happens but they don't
think about it in terms of return on
investment my advice is to think about
everything in terms of allocation of
resources where do I get the highest
returns simply look at the payroll
against how much business you expect
that person to bring in and you compare
them against The Benchmark of the team
and over time that Benchmark should
raise because everyone should be getting
better